et pour parler de l'épidémie de kovy 19
je suis avec marion de chine ali en
visio bonsoir la directrice de la
délégation départementale des yvelines
de la rs ile-de-france les rs et bien
sûr l'agencé régionale de santé
dimanche plus de 7000 cas positifs ont
été enregistrés en 24 heures en france
est ce que les indicateurs sont aussi
inquiétants en région ile de france et
dans le département des yvelines alors
la région ile de france est classée
rouge depuis maintenant à peu près 15
jours et pour les yvelines le seuil
l'esade alerte à la fois sur les taux
d'incidence et les taux de positivité
ont été dépassées il ya maintenant dix
jours effectivement donc on est
également classée rouge ce qui prouve
qu'il ya une vraie circulation du virus
circulation du virus est ce qu on a
aussi des statistiques inquiétantes du
côté des hôpitaux ce qui a davantage
d'entrée à l'hôpital de patients qui
sont placées en réanimation
non alors au niveau de l'hôpital on voit
convient pas du tout la même chose qu'au
mois de mars il ya une progression qui
est lente et continue depuis maintenant
la mini le milieu de l'été
mais par contre c'est une scission et
j'ai une situation qui reste
complètement gérable et géré par les
hôpitaux on est vraiment sûr
effectivement une circulation du virus
avec des cas qui sont moins graves pour
ce qu'on a connu